hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 17 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet things totally went off the
rails and it's so much more fun now as
predicted hive has turned one of the
secret warriors I feel like up to a
couple episodes ago they were teasing us
with Lincoln turning just because he had
that dark side classic bait-and-switch
Daisy is the one that gets turned and
crazy Daisy is my favorite Daisy
Chloe Bennett the actress has been doing
a lot better job I think she'll have a
lot more fun with the character now that
she gets to go off the rails going off
the rails is one of the most fun things
to do for a character that's normally
supposed to have their together
like grant Ward in season 1 was this
total vanilla character the most boring
thing ever
then big twist in the back half of the
season turns out he's Hydra and he goes
completely off the rails so much more
interesting so let's do top five WTF
there were a couple of comic book Easter
eggs but largely all the comic book
stuff is being pulled from secret
warriors from that storyline in the
comics there is some Civil War stuff
that's gonna be happening in a couple
weeks but I don't know exactly how
that's gonna go down we could talk about
that at the end of the video so number 5
Avengers Assemble Daisy gets the band
back together really digging the energy
between Joey and yo-yo they're both new
to the team but they're really excited
to be there do something good with their
powers and it was a really nice touch
you know from a creative standpoint just
to have them speak Spanish to each other
just like it was no big deal like they
have a special bond within the bond that
they're both part of the secret warriors
we're both in humans we're both part of
this special team but we also have this
real world cultural link that Bond's us
that's totally normal even though
they're totally badass superheroes with
crazy powers speaking Spanish to each
other just makes them feel more like
real characters and then later it's so
much sweeter when Mack does it like oh
you've been you've been studying up like
there's some sort of ship that's
developing between them
you can definitely tell he went above
and beyond the call of duty it is not a
shield requirement that you learn
Spanish so yeah there's definitely some
chemistry between them which they kind
of use to pull the rug out from under
you at the end where everybody's stopped
trusting each other so number 4 WTF they
find out that hive has infected one of
the team members and they do the classic
whodunit like there's a wolf in the
henhouse which one of us is the traitor
it's like a game of Clue Daisy in the
interrogation room with the bomb best
part of this is the Coulson first
perspective shots as he was walking out
just looking at all the in Hulme
it's like is it this person is it one of
these two this is like the best version
of Coulson it always feels really
unnatural when he starts trusting people
but he's like the Nick Fury on the team
and Nick Fury doesn't trust anyone if
you haven't read the comics you should
check out original sin you will learn so
many amazing things about Nick Fury and
why it's so important for him to not
trust anyone so that's kind of like the
Coulson character so paranoid Coulson
always feels like the best version of
Coulson
number three WTF Malik's confession oh
he's a god he's just not our God I love
the way the show is talking around the
hive character like you see Brett
Dalton's performance when he's playing
the character he's very understated as
opposed to say zoom on the flash is a
bit more of a showy villain so most of
the hive action is actually coming from
the characters around him so listening
to Malick talked about trying to bring a
God back in finding out that it was
really the devil masquerading as a god
the devil makes all kinds of promises
Coulson throws in a nice low-key jab
I've met gods before which makes you
feel like there's gonna be a destroyer
gun moment we developed this after our
first encounter with you it's so new
even I don't know what it does let's
turn it on don't you want to find out
what it does usually any time Coulson
talks about shading a god or shading
some powerful being it's calling back to
that Loki encounter where you you know a
God is able to run rampant all over man
but that doesn't mean that Coulson won't
be the one to get the last word in so
everybody just hold your breath and wait
for a destroyer gun moment number two
WTF thankfully paying off the Fitz and
Simmons romance usually it's really hard
for series to get the level of like
romance and shipping right usually they
go too far or they don't do it quite
enough
I feel like Shield has done a pretty
good job with it this season like yes
it's happening
yes we're finally getting that together
but just as this is happening things go
off the rails with Daisy so my number
one WTF Daisy starts to destroy the base
that was one of my most fun moments just
that crazy smile on her face it was so
perfect this is my new favorite Daisy
moment yeah it was totally cool seeing
her go through terrigenesis watch her
powers be activated but now watching her
go off the rails is the most beautiful
thing ever so let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from this was it like the twist at the
end where Daisy's like I'm the best I've
ever been
I'm so happy now I'm just gonna go ahead
and destroy this entire base just a
reminder this was episode 17 there are
22 episodes of this season total so
there's still five more episodes to go
so we still got to find out how yo-yos a
bloody cross ends up in outer space she
might be the one that dies we don't know
that yet
we just know it's gonna be somebody
wearing a shield uniform meaning that
it's probably one of the secret warriors
so what we're seeing here is a vision
that Daisy had of someone dying in the
future it could be her death it could be
someone close to her but she's close to
all the secret warriors
I feel like of all the people she cares
about most Lincoln is probably at the
top of that list so I'm gonna say yo-yo
and Lincoln are on the hit list for the
end of the season but let me know in the
comments who do you think is the dead
secret warrior that's in this scene
right here but let's talk about some
Captain America Civil War crossover so
Civil Wars coming out that first week in
May there are two episodes that could
potentially be that crossover episode
there's episode 19 that's called failed
experiments and then the week after that
is called emancipation so I feel like
those two episodes are gonna have some
sort of Civil War crossover but they did
say that it's gonna be a one-way thing
so they'll address Civil War on the TV
show but the movie is not going to
address what's going on in the TV show
so instead of using the term Inhumans
the movie is gonna use the term enhanced
people like Scarlet Witch is an enhanced
person but the term failed experiments
really just sounds like Kree failed
experiments as in the Inhumans were
considered a failed experiment by the
creek so the Kree bailed and left them
to their own devices so I think they've
actually teased that the Kree will be
coming back to the show this season in
some form or another they have that
special orb so it's probably gonna have
something to do with defeating hive so
I'm expecting the Creed to give them
some knowledge as to how that all works
and how to banish hive they'll probably
like yeah there's no way to kill him you
can only contain him there was also some
anti hive research when hive was first
taking over Hydra he went around and hit
a bunch of military bases Simmons was
talking about birds you know like Alfred
Hitchcock's the birds like Oh wouldn't
you be terrified if a bunch of birds
came pecking at you the research that
hive destroyed was working towards an
immunity to his parasitic effect so it'd
be like inoculating people against his
form of mind control so that will also
probably have something to do with the
Emancipation episode
but the other really big news is that
Gotham just introduced the Azrael
character if he never read him in the
comics he kind of took over his Batman
he's part of this special order of crazy
lunatics he's a total badass the TV show
version of the character is actually
someone who's dead who came back so it's
all part of this big Hugo Strange plot
so if you haven't been watching Gotham
now's a good time to get back on but I
will be doing a Gotham video on my
youtube channel for Azrael they drop
this really big cinematic trailers
really cool so be sure to subscribe to
get that there's also a big Doctor
Strange video I'm working on and a lot
of you had questions about the flash so
I'll try to address that in another
video this week while you guys wait for
my next video to post you can click here
for last night's episode of the flash
and you can click here to learn all
about Marvel phase 4 thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you